enfin j'ouvre notre second débat débat
de société consacrée ce soir aux
violences conjugales plus de 200-7000
personnes en ont été victimes en 2021
sur les chiffres du ministère de
l'Intérieur dans leur immense immense
majorité évidemment sont des femmes pour
qu'il la réponse judiciaire est encore
inadapté la preuve avec ce reportage de
Cécile Siksou auprès de Caroline femme
battue pendant 15 ans pendant 15 ans
Caroline a été victime de violences
conjugales la première fois qu'elle
dépose plainte contre son conjoint elle
est choquée par la réponse de la justice
on a été reçu par la substitut du
procureur à l'époque tous les deux
et là je peux vous dire que c'est un
moment terrible
en fait la substitue la cérémonie comme
un enfant
vous rendez compte monsieur ce que vous
avez fait ça ne se fait pas etc je vous
prie de bien vouloir présenter vos
excuses à Madame et ne plus jamais
recommencer
donc devant la substitut du procureur il
m'a présenté ses excuses et là je me
suis dit mais que se passe-t-il quoi on
n'est pas des enfants et en fait ça
s'est terminé comme ça quelques années
plus tard son compagnon pointe une arme
sur elle elle dépose de nouveau plaintes
classées sans suite en fait on m'a pas
cru quoi donc
[Musique]
donc à ce moment là ça a été violent
parce que je me suis dit mais tout ce
que j'ai vécu enfin je l'ai bien vécu
et la justice veut pas l'entendre on
veut pas on veut pas me protéger on veut
pas me reconnaître en tant que victime
on veut pas m'aider à me sortir de ça
c'est déception de Caroline face à la
réponse de la justice est un phénomène
vécu par la plupart des victimes quand
elles se retrouvent devant les tribunaux
les juges ne répondent pas à leurs
besoins de mise en sécurité souvent par
manque de formation et cela peut parfois
avoir des conséquences dramatiques
allant jusqu'au féminicides malgré
plusieurs signalements un tribunal en a
pris conscience à Chalon en Champagne un
pôle spécialisé a été mis en place en
2019 les magistrats ont été formés
donc bonjour madame chez Madame Chavanne
je suis magistrat du parquet donc ça je
vais vous remettre donc le téléphone
grave danger vous n'hésitez pas à
appuyer vous sera jamais reproché
d'avoir déclenché une alerte Camille
Chabanne est substitut procureur formé
au phénomène d'emprise elle sait comment
rassurer les victimes et décrypter leur
comportement parfois on a des victimes
qui ne souhaitent pas tout de suite un
téléphone grave danger et puis
finalement par la suite vont le
solliciter pour pour presque se rassurer
mais en fait l'idée c'est que c'est
victime reprennent aussi toute la
confiance en toute confiance en elle
et pour qu'après elle puisse se défaire
en fait de du contrôle qui a pu mettre
en place le conjoint violent ici la
spécialisation passe aussi par l'échange
entre les juges une fois par semaine
Camille Chaban participait des réunions
avec les autres magistrats ils font le
point sur les affaires en cours on a
plusieurs constatations de blessures de
bleu etc
c'est tout quoi elle avait pas donné
d'explications sur ce qui s'était passé
où elle avait donné une fausse
explication
j'ai plus les détails en tête ouais
détecter les victimes pour la procureur
du tribunal 4 ans après sa mise en place
la politique de spécialisation porte ses
fruits le bilan au plan quantitatif il
est assez clair on a davantage de
d'affaires qui nous arrive qui nous sont
orientés et c'est plutôt bon signe
paradoxalement parce que ça veut dire
que les plaintes elles émergent elles
sont prises dans les services de police
le parquet est avisé et donc on a des
dossiers qui sont pris en compte mais
au-delà de ça on le constate dans la
réponse pénale les réponses pénales
d'urgence ont énormément augmenté
beaucoup d'affaires étaient classées
sans suite auparavant les restes
évidemment des classements sur suite
mais beaucoup moins puisqu'on a pu
travailler sur la qualité des dossiers
de procédure et la qualité des preuves
c'est pôle spécialisées devraient se
généraliser la première ministre a
annoncé vouloir en créer de son en
France
et sur ce thème ne ratez pas ce samedi
18h sur Public Sénat le documentaire
violence conjugale une justice à la
peine réalisée par Cécile sigsous qui
vient de de nous présenter ce sujet
Chalon en Champagne on y était qui va
servir de modèle au 200 poules
spécialisés qui seront créés en France
on en parle tout de suite avec Dominique
verrière bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
sénatrice centriste de l'Yonne
vice-présidente de la délégation au
droit des femmes et à l'égalité des
chances entre les hommes et les femmes
et co-autrices d'un rapport sur le
traitement des violences intra
familiales Céline pig bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes présidente de
la commission violence du Haut Conseil à
l'égalité Victoria vano bonsoir vous
aussi docteur en droit ingénieur de
recherche au CNRS et puis auteur de ce
livre la paix déménages histoire des
violences conjugales 19ème et 20e siècle
aux éditions à la Mossa j'accueille
également en duplex Eric corbeau qui est
procureur général à la Cour d'appel de
Poitiers bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et Mathieu croissanto
est resté à mes côtés
je commence avec ces pôles spécialisés
donc
annonce par la première ministre il y a
un mois
c'était l'une des recommandations de
votre rapport tout à fait quel sera le
rôle comment ça va fonctionner alors en
fait l'objectif c'est on se rend compte
que dans ce genre de de litige de délit
il y a une vraie technicité à avoir il y
a des connaissances à avoir pour pouvoir
instruire ces dossiers tant du côté de
la police que de la justice et donc ces
chambres spécialisées côté du siège ou
ces pôles spécialisés côté du parquet
l'idée est d'avoir les mêmes juges que
dans une chambre normale mais avec une
formation accrue sur ces sujets là et
surtout un partage d'informations pour
ne pas avoir un juge d'affaires
familiales qui prend une décision en
méconnaissance que le juge va faire
pénal dans la même affaire aura pu
statuer mais sur une autre personne
puisque aujourd'hui on ne s'intéresse
qu'à l'auteur quand on est en justice
pénale et que le juge des enfants puisse
lui prendre encore une troisième
décision qui pourrait venir en
contradiction ou ne pas tenir compte
souvent ça ne communique pas souvent ça
ne communique pas et réellement et
d'ailleurs à chaque fois que ces
chambres ont été mises en place vous
parliez de Châlons-en-Champagne mais
c'est le cas à Clermont-Ferrand c'est le
cas il y a en règle générale un
assistant de justice qui permet à la
l'information de d'être diffusé d'être
communiqué de faire que tout le monde
est le même niveau d'information y
comprennent des décisions sur les
connaissances et d'ailleurs on va plus
loin nous puisque nous proposons aussi
un dossier unique de situation qui
prennent en compte la cellule familiale
et pas seulement l'auteur ou pas
seulement l'enfant pas seulement la
femme et bien la cellule familiale ils
comprennent des décisions par rapport à
ça c'est une pique votre réaction sur
ces pôles spécialisés c'est un progrès
c'est bon nous enfin moi personnellement
j'étais plus partante sur une autre
solution qui était effectivement une
juridiction spécialisée qui permet
effectivement d'arrêter de ce travail en
silo puisqu'on voit bien que juge aux
affaires familiales jugent des enfants
et puis procédure pénale aujourd'hui
sont complètement fermées donc
finalement les propositions que vous
faites si je comprends bien c'est
finalement institutionnalisé des bonnes
pratiques existent déjà dans les
juridictions j'ai un peu peur que ce
soit insuffisant parce que ça changera
le juridiction spécialisée c'est de la
c'est un peu le modèle espagnol et c'est
ça a été le sens de la proposition de
loi qui a été faite en octobre 2022 par
ailleurs ce serait effectivement d'avoir
la possibilité de dans un même moment et
sans différence de temporalité et et
j'irai cassé complètement ces silos à
juger en même temps la question des
violences et la question des des enfants
puisqu'on sait c'est quelque chose que
les associations féministes rappellent
depuis des années un mari violent n'est
jamais un bon père et on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec ses aberrations en
termes de violence post séparation avec
l'enfant qui est au centre des conflits
au centre des violences entre
l'ex-conjointe et le mari violent donc
je pense que ça va dans le bon sens
puisque finalement ça met au cœur de
de la question cette transversalité et
le fait de prendre la question dans son
ensemble mais je pense que ce sera
effectivement insuffisant votre réponse
et puis après je vais faire en sorte que
la parole se distribue sur l'Espagne
chronique dans un instant
civiles et le pénal et le pénal et le
juge trois ans après il y a pas du tout
la même temporalité contrairement à ce
que nous nous croyons quand nous y avons
vraiment consacrer un chapitre mais je
voudrais d'abord entendre mes deux
autres invités sur cette idée de de pôle
spécialisée peut-être le fait que
effectivement il y avait il y avait une
justice qui était un peu quoi concentré
dans pas vers les juges aux affaires
familiales qui étaient un petit peu dans
leur dans leur coin face à ces dossiers
c'est ça c'est la spécificité du 20e et
du 21e siècle la concentration de ces
cas de violences conjugales pas traitée
par le juge d'affaires familiales alors
qu'au 19e siècle c'était le juge pénal
et l'absence de communication si vous
voulez qu'il se pose aujourd'hui entre
le jeu à faire fam le juge aux enfants
et le juge correctionnel ne se posait
pas dans les mêmes termes aujourd'hui
depuis le 20e siècle on va dire c'est le
juge de l'affaire familiale qui traite
le cas des violences conjugales et
effectivement c'est pas lui le bleu juge
le plus à même de traiter ce qui relève
de la violence qui derrière cache des
délits des crimes très importants qui
pourraient traiter également le cas des
enfants puisque se pose aussi évidemment
parfois effectivement vous l'évoquez
tout à l'heure la violence qui peuvent
déborder sur les enfants et donc
finalement quelque part c'est une
avancée alors évidemment faut voir ce
que ça peut donner mais je sais que il y
a des travaux dans sciences sociales qui
ont travaillé sur les audiences dédiées
qui ont fait remonter effectivement
cette spécialisation là de certains
audience dédiée également
Eric corbeau votre avis sur comment ça
pourrait se mettre en place un tel pôle
spécialisé dans les violences
intrafamidales par exemple évidemment à
Poitiers est-ce que ça suppose qu'il y a
des moyens supplémentaires
si vous me permettez à un regard de
praticien il y a plusieurs choses on a
vu dans le reportage des cellules de
veille elles existent maintenant dans à
peu près toutes les juridictions c'est à
dire des partages d'informations entre
les juges des enfants et juste à faire
familiales le parquet pour essayer de
mieux cerner les situations
effectivement on en est pas encore là à
la justice spécialisée que madame la
sénatrice évoquée néanmoins ce qu'il
faut effectivement constater et là je
m'inscris un petit peu en fou le juge
correctionnel traite énormément de
violence de questions de violence
conjugales la moitié des permanences
pénales des parquets traitent de
violence conjugales aller dans une
permanence de parquet vous verrez que
l'essentiel des appels téléphoniques
reçues par la permanence des parquets
concernent des violences conjugales la
moitié des comparutions immédiates ce
sont des violences conjugales donc on a
effectivement une une spécialisation
déjà un petit peu de fait du juge aussi
pénal en matière de violence conjugale
dire que seul le jaspe c'est c'est faux
le juge pénal aussi s'en occupe
quasiment
en permanence et les permanences des
parquets ne font que ça et c'est très
bien sur la spécialisation j'avais écrit
avec madame jolicoz qui est la première
président de la cour d'appel de Poitiers
on avait écrit une tribune dans Le Monde
fin décembre sur ce sujet pour proposer
effectivement une démarche résolutive de
dire global d'une situation comme vous
venez effectivement de l'indiquer c'est
à dire que
puis une même concentration de
spécialistes les enfants juste de la
faire familiales juge pénale traité
l'ensemble d'une situation alors on a
des tout petits soucis techniques donc
toutes les juridictions c'est que vous
êtes en proximité si vous créez une
juridiction spécialisée vous vous allez
vous éloigner du terrain et donc être
beaucoup moins en proximité de la
situation des gens et il faut être très
en proximité pour les connaître alors
j'espère que la liaison va va rester
correcte pour pouvoir vous redonner la
parole régulièrement Eric corbeau on
voulait parler de l'Espagne on y vient
maintenant grâce à Jonathan du prière
rebonsoir Jonathan bienvenue sur ce
plateau l'Espagne qu'on présente souvent
comme l'élève modèle de l'Europe les
féminicides y ont chuté de 25% en moins
de 20 ans ouais et tout est parti d'une
affaire en particulier qui a bouleversé
la société espagnole c'était en 1997
cette femme elle s'appelait Anna
oranteste elle a été battue pendant 40
ans par son mari elle avait déposé 15
plaintes contre lui et quelques jours
après avoir raconté son calvaire à la
télévision espagnole et bien son
conjoint la brûlé vive et l'émotion a
été immense dans le pays et ça a poussé
l'Espagne à créer des tribunaux
spécialisés dans les violences
conjugales là on était en 2004
aujourd'hui il y en a 106 dans le pays
et notre collègue Cécile sigsous donc
vous avez pu voir un extrait de son
documentaire elle sait rendu à Madrid
dans l'un de ses tribunaux regardés
ce jour-là le tribunal de Madrid juge un
homme qui a proféré des menaces de mort
à l'encontre de sa femme
une routine pour la magistrate Noemi
moonieco qui statue exclusivement sur
des affaires de violence conjugales
d'un point de vue pénal on travaille sur
une matière technique mais très réduite
au final il y a peu de délits différents
au sein de notre juridiction
rapide les procès se répètent
la majorité des cas est assez similaire
et présente les mêmes caractéristiques
la préparation t'oblige à être à jour et
cela nous permet d'être plus efficace
il y a une spécialisation dans la
matière cela nous permet d'analyser les
cas plus en profondeur avec plus de
professionnalisme
juridiction spécialisée sur les
violences conjugales ça veut dire quoi
concrètement alors c'est il y a beaucoup
de choses un Thomas sont des
juridictions genre tout d'abord où on ne
juge en fait que des hommes et seulement
sur des affaires qui concernent des
violences conjugales donc ces tribunaux
ils ont aussi des spécifications
notamment ils ont des unités médicales
pour constater directement sur place les
blessures des victimes il y a aussi des
policiers pourquoi pas pour recueillir
des plaintes directement à noter aussi
que les magistrats et bien ils ont des
formations spéciales pour pouvoir
appréhender ces victimes
particulièrement et ses auteurs et les
délais pour statuer sont extrêmement
rapides ça peut aller jusqu'à 72 heures
pour avoir un on va dire un jugement
provisoire et permettre de protéger en
fait femmes et enfants en danger isolé
pourquoi pas les auteurs avec un
bracelet électronique pour l'éloigner de
sa famille s'il y a péril écouter
d'ailleurs à ce sujet un magistrat
madrilène qui lui aussi a parlé apparaît
dans ce reportage il détaille un petit
peu tout ça
quand une femme porte plainte si elle se
sent menacée ou en danger elle demande
au juge une ordonnance de protection
la décision prise par le juge peut
consister en une injonction
d'éloignement afin que l'accusé ne
puisse ni s'approcher ni entrer en
communication avec elle
et surtout cela permet de résoudre de
façon immédiate et temporaire la
question de savoir qui reste au domicile
familiale qui a la garde des enfants et
le montant de la pension inversée voilà
en tout cas si le système espagnol a
l'air d'être un modèle il est encore
imparfait le pays d'ailleurs connaît
actuellement une recrudescence de
féminicides il y a encore on peut dire
que c'est un fléau qui n'est pas encore
endigué en tout cas je vous invite donc
à regarder ce reportage de Cécile Siksou
samedi à 18h sur Public Sénat qui
s'intitule violence conjugale une
justice à la peine merci beaucoup
Jonathan du priez Céline pic votre avis
donc on a commencé à aborder la question
du du modèle espagnol et je reviens sur
finalement cette question ça peut
sembler un peu technique mais
juridiction spécialisée ou pôle
spécialisée
Eric corbeau disait les peaux
spécialisés on y gagne en proximité
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez tout dépend peut-être des moyens
qu'on veut y mettre en fait on peut ne
pas perdre la proximité imaginer des
juridictions spécialisées a été dit on
parle aujourd'hui de 50% des affaires
aujourd'hui les violences sexistes et
sexuelles c'est quelque chose de
totalement massif et on verra peut-être
à
l'usage du temps mais je pense que ça ne
sera pas suffisant la coordination
j'entends bien elle peut être
intéressante mais de statuer en
particulier dans les situations
d'urgence comme ça a été dit sur la
capacité de de décider très rapidement
de la Garde etc le choix qui a été fait
par l'Espagne effectivement différent du
choix français après dans le modèle
espagnol il y a aussi plein d'autres
choses donc pour dont on pourrait
s'inspirer peut-être que c'est dans la
suite de votre je veux pas
le recensement des des femmes à risque
entre guillemets je pense que dans les
enfin dans les modèles sur lequel on
pourrait s'inspirer c'est la culture du
chiffre du chiffre de à différentes
façons c'est à dire il y a une
publication de statistiques qui est
beaucoup plus avancée je pense qu'on
devrait avancer en termes de
d'évaluation des politiques publiques
parce que depuis 2017 date à laquelle a
été déclaré la grande cause du
quinquennat on a enchaîné effectivement
les législations les différentes lois et
ça va à chaque fois petit pas par petit
pas dans le bon sens la question c'est
le déploiement des dispositifs si on
prend un exemple dans les ordonnances de
protection on est à plus de 30000
ordonnances de protection en Espagne on
en est encore très très loin en France
donc aujourd'hui en France il y a aussi
l'effectivité des mesures qui sont
votées et là il y a la question des
moyens il y a la question des la
formation des magistrats est-ce que les
magistrats se saisissent réellement de
l'ensemble de l'Arsenal législative qui
a été développé ces dernières années
votre avis là-dessus de mais il va rien
sur les moyens c'est à dire que là il y
a une nouvelle ambition de quel moyen
quel moyen sont nécessaires pour que
elle soit effectivement deux choses pour
parce que là on a vu deux juges au
niveau espagnol la première c'était la
juge pénale qui jugeait une affaire qui
avait déjà trois ans et l'autre c'est le
juge aux affaires familiales qui lui
effectivement est bien meilleur dans
l'urgence que chez nous et d'ailleurs ça
fait partie de certaines de nos
précausonisations d'aller plus dans
l'urgence et ensuite je ne peux vous
rejoindre sur le fait que l'Espagne a un
modèle exemplaire notamment dans le
pilotage de sa politique publique sur ce
sujet là et c'est quelqu'un ça
correspond au Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature qui est missionné pour
suivre très exactement mais donc nous
nous demandons effectivement un pilotage
interministériel sur ce sujet et avec un
fond dédié alors voilà je voulais vous
dire justement avancer pilotage de
terrain
des magistrats supplémentaires mais moi
j'ai bien entendu et c'est pas tombé
dans l'oreille d'une sourde 1500
magistrats 1500 greffiers 10000
assistantes dans les 5 ans qui viennent
et nous avons dit que à partir du moment
où 30% des affaires comme le disait
effectivement le procureur
minimum 30% des affaires concernent des
violences intrafamilales il nous faut au
minimum 30% de ses forces
supplémentaires qui soient totalement
dédiée à cette politique et un fond
également dédié parce que en fait à
chaque fois on parle d'une manière qu'on
a pas retrouvé non plus en Espagne cela
dit mais le fait de pouvoir vraiment
savoir qu'est-ce qui est dédié
réellement à cette politique et du coup
pouvoir mieux accompagner les
associations parce que contrairement à
l'Espagne chez nous c'est un système
très associatif Victoria vano les moyens
mis en oeuvre par l'Espagne je sais pas
c'est pas une colle mais
est-ce que c'est effectivement sans
commune mesure avec ce que ce que la
France a pu faire là franchement c'est
vraiment une colle pour moi je pourrai
pas la question à Céline
millions qui a été mis sur la table et
je pense que la méthode aussi ça a été
elle a été différente dans le sens où on
a l'impression nous on empile les
propositions de loi depuis plusieurs
années en Espagne il y a eu
effectivement il y a eu une grande loi
cadre et je pense que aussi c'est ça
dont on pourrait peut-être s'inspirer
c'est que là on a l'impression qu'on
revient sur le métier tous les six mois
il y a un nouveau rapport tous les six
mois il y a un nouveau texte encore une
fois par exemple sur l'autorité
parentale qui est vraiment une des
revendications depuis très très
longtemps
des associations féministes pour dire
qu'il faut faire des retraits d'autorité
parentale en cas de violence intra
familiale on est revenu sur une loi qui
avait déjà été introduite en 2019 pour
les auteurs de féminicides et on vient à
nouveau les tendres etc donc vraiment on
aimerait et l'association féministe qui
parle aux efféminines mange que je
représente également qui est
effectivement une une ambition politique
qui est une cohérence et qui est
vraiment quelque chose qui soit
une priorité de politique publique au
niveau du ministère de l'Intérieur
depuis quand on recense les violences
intraconjugales en France est-ce que
c'était dans le code pénal dès le début
c'est passé voilà historique
conjugale ou de violence intra-famille
c'est pas la même chose déjà alors les
violences conjugales ont les considère
pas vraiment au 19e siècle si ce n'est
comme motif des crimes les plus graves
donc on parle de dissension domestique
donc on commence un petit peu à avoir
apparaître ça en 1826 et puis ensuite
régulièrement dans les comptes de la
justice criminelle mais là on parle de
dissension domestique donc ce qu'on
pourrait comparer à des violences
conjugales les violences intrafamiales
c'est beaucoup plus large que ça sont
les violences dans le couple les
violences à l'égard des enfants les
violences des enfants à les garder
parents donc faut ça faut se mettre
d'accord d'abord sur le la définition et
le périmètre en tout cas de ce qu'on
entend par violence intrafamiliale mais
on les compte on va dire depuis que on
décide de porter des statistiques donc
depuis 1826 mais pas en tant que on va
dire phénomène social mais en tant que
motif des crimes capitaux les plus
graves c'est différent de ce qu'on
appelait autrefois les crimes
passionnels
c'est pareil c'est une terminologie on
va dire journalistique un peu comme ce
qui on a eu pour le féminicide qui est
passé un petit peu dans les dans les
médias le crime passionnel c'est juste
un motif la passion c'est un motif des
crimes les plus graves dans le contexte
conjugal
Eric corbeau vous vouliez intervenir et
je ne vous oublie pas j'espère que la
liaison est meilleure que que tout à
l'heure le modèle espagnol voilà
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez est-ce
qu'on peut le dupliquer l'appliquer en
France
mais il est certain qu'il y a eu des
moyens qu'il y a effectivement une
accompagnement associatif aussi qui est
très important et qui là peut nécessiter
des moyens financiers importants pour
accompagner les associations on peut
quand même remarquer que depuis quelques
années les outils effectivement sont
venus renforcer le rôle du juge le
téléphone grave danger on en a vu dans
le reportage c'est multiplié par 10 en 5
ans le bracelet anti rapprochement est
devenu une mesure habituelle maintenant
l'ordonnance de protection se prononce
en moins de six jours donc on est sur
effectivement il y a des choses qui ont
énormément progressé ce qu'on attend
c'est peut-être effectivement c'est pôle
spécialisés qui vont regrouper de
manière institutionnelle les compétences
et peut-être permettre une prise en
charge globale avec des suivis qui
soient possibles sur l'ensemble des
specs du spectre finalement judiciaires
de la personne que ce soit mineur à
faire familiale pénal et ensuite
application des peines aussi pour les
auteurs suite à leur exécution de paix
donc il faut effectivement avoir cette
vision là qui soit démarche une démarche
réseau utile de problèmes on traite un
problème de fond qui est qui sont les
violences conjugales dans notre pays il
faut plus le traiter de manière en silo
comme on le disait tout à l'heure il
faut traiter de manière globale alors on
va détailler les mesures notamment de
protection des victimes on parlera aussi
des enfants d'ailleurs dans ce débat je
vous propose d'écouter ce que propose
Ernestine renek et fondatrice de
l'Observatoire des violences faites aux
femmes elle nous dit il faut penser la
protection en la séparant de la sanction
écoutez
il faut absolument que dans notre pays
dans les progrès que nous devons faire
notre société pense mieux la gravité des
violences faites aux femmes première
chose leur danger la dangerosité des
hommes violents et l'imprévisibilité des
hommes violents il faut donc qu'on pense
la protection en la séparant de la
sanction une chose est de dire il y a la
présomption d'innocence pour la sanction
une deuxième et de dire il faut qu'on
soit dans un principe de précaution et
qu'on protège les femmes lorsqu'elles
révèle des violences et la révélation
des violences n'est jamais la première
violence subie en général ils en ont
déjà subi pas mal Dominique va rien ça
veut dire quoi appliquer ce principe de
précaution c'est éloigné le mari du
domicile conduit
d'ailleurs de nos mesures et là pour le
coup très probablement inspiré de notre
voyage en Espagne de mieux gérer
l'urgence et donc nous préconisons et la
première ministre la reprise dans ces
préconisations du 8 mars une ordonnance
d'éviction du conjoint immédiate
c'est-à-dire que tout de suite on
éloigne et ensuite ça laisse le temps au
juge de la faire familiales d'introduire
le contradictoire puisque il est obligé
de le faire mais dans un premier temps
on protège la femme et après on commence
à discuter mais on ne laisse pas en
attendant que le juge et le temps de se
saisir du dossier on ne laisse pas la
femme chez elle avec son conjoint
violent et donc voilà dans un premier
temps les sépare et dans un deuxième
temps
on fait jouer le contrat c'est une pique
c'est encore trop souvent ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est souvent c'est la
femme qu'on éloigne du domicile mais
elle est forcée de partir par la force
des choses mettre en sécurité
effectivement et ça a été un petit peu
changé pendant le confinement d'ailleurs
avec davantage d'éloignement du conjoint
violent et par rapport à cette culture
de la protection je trouve ça
extrêmement intéressant ce que disait
Ernestine René et là aussi si on comme
pas encore lu le rapport donc je me base
encore à nouveau sur le modèle espagnol
sur en Espagne cette culture de la
protection elle fait intervenir
également les associations de terrain
avec un fichier qui partagé par tous ou
je crois qu'il y a maintenant 50 000
femmes qui sont suivies avec un niveau
de dangerosité qui est réévalué en temps
réel en fait avec une sorte de vous êtes
en verre orange rouge et en fonction des
signals d'alerte même des signaux
faibles qui ne vont pas nécessairement
aller vers une plainte par exemple des
menaces par SMS une femme qui se déplace
dans une association pour faire état de
menaces ou de violence sans
nécessairement passer par la case
plainte et ben ces informations vont
rentrer être rentrées dans ce dans ce
fichier et va permettre d'évaluer en
temps réel le niveau de danger donc là
effectivement il y a une séparation
entre la réponse pénale a donné à
l'auteur de violence et puis une culture
de la protection d'avoir la capacité en
temps réel d'évaluer le niveau de
dangerosité et le niveau de danger
auquel est exposé cette femme
d'ailleurs effectivement le fichier fait
partie de nos préconisations mais
également le fait de pouvoir donner plus
facilement à téléphone grave danger
y compris pas forcément par le juge
parce que on s'en rend compte moi dans
mon département
l'association d'aide aux victimes donne
mon bouton mon chéri mais il y a aussi
des applications il y a l'application
Apple un moyen qui fait que alors
effectivement c'est pas un policier qui
va intervenir mais ça permet de prévenir
un ami si jamais la personne arrive donc
là c'est un bouton qui est posé sur le
soutien-gorge et la personne appuie
dessus et ça va appeler quelqu'un donc
on sait qu'elle est en danger et qu'il
faut donc intervenir et je pense que là
on peut télé on peut donner ses
téléphones graves danger de façon un peu
plus large que ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
et donc on préconise nous que notamment
des associations agréées puissent donner
des téléphones graves danger quand elles
sentent que c'est nécessaire même sans
avoir tout de suite la position du juge
alors justement on a on a on a les
chiffres sur les ce téléphone grave
danger dont vous nous parlez la
progression effectivement
4680 téléphones vont manger déployés en
juridiction
3451 sont attribués donc c'est les trois
on va dire les trois quarts 64% du
dispositif Éric corbeau dans quel cas
sont-ils distribués c'est ça marche
comment pardon de vous poser une
question un peu un peu basique comme ça
un peu trivial
là aussi on a évolué la loi évoluer
maintenant on peut l'attribuer dès qu'il
y a une suspicion de danger dès qu'il y
a donc déclaration de danger alors on
est effectivement au niveau d'une
plainte déposée par la victime mais avec
suspicion danger on peut à ce moment-là
attribuer un téléphone grave danger ça
se fait effectivement comme il disait
madame la sénatrice par l'intermédiaire
du magistrat du parquet qui attribue ce
téléphone grave danger et qui après
permet d'être géolocalisé et d'alerter
immédiatement un service d'assistance et
donc de police et de gendarmerie qui
peut intervenir très vite donc on est
sur quelque chose qui s'attribue de
manière beaucoup plus facile
qu'auparavant c'est ce qui a aussi
permis son expansion qui est maintenant
la suspicion de danger elle suffit on
attend plus d'avoir effectivement mené
une enquête
pour voir s'il est fait elle se contente
d'une suspicion
on parlait Victor Lanaud de la
présomption d'innocence et de la
difficulté finalement de concilier cette
présomption avec la protection des
victimes elle a elle a servi les maries
violents pendant pendant trop longtemps
cette présence elle a servi puis en plus
le Code d'instruction criminelle qui
lançait être du code de procédure pénale
n'autorisez pas les femmes à témoigner
et porter plainte contre leur mari donc
du coup c'était très très compliqué pour
pour la justice de pouvoir travailler il
y avait une présomption on va dire un
peu favorable parce que traîner un peu
dans les esprits l'idée que le mari
avait le droit de battre sa femme donc
il y avait cette résurgence un peu
moyenâgeuse du droit de correction mais
les juristes et notamment les pénalistes
du 19e siècle c'était très attachés au
fait que ça c'était le passé et qui
n'était pas question de laisser on va
dire la tyrannie s'imposer dans ces dans
ces conjugalités là mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que dès 18 5 donc les
magistrats reconnaissent en tout cas une
compétence de la norme pénale pour toute
violence au sein du couple mais surtout
quelle que soit la qualité de la victime
là tout à l'heure on parle donc de
juridiction genre de jugement que
d'hommes mais les violences conjugales
également au 19e siècle concerné aussi
des femmes qui viennent hanter leur mari
et si on tire le fil encore aujourd'hui
on a les couples homosexuels les couples
lesbiens et du coup d'avoir des
juridictions très genrées comme en 2010
on avait voulu en France instaurer à
violence de genre dans le code pénal ça
pose effectivement des problèmes
d'égalité de droits et d'égalité de
traitement et là la question de la
présomption d'innocence elle se pose
surtout en contexte de conflit conjugal
ou c'est difficile de démêler le vrai du
faux ou les coûts sont donnés dans un
peu réciproquement et la question de la
contre-violence et souvent abordée et
mis en avant pour pour les femmes
d'ailleurs dans quand on prend les
chiffres de la délégation victime de la
police et de la gendarmerie nationale
sur ces les violences conjugales et les
morts et les mortes 143 décès en 2021
122 femmes et 21 hommes Céline pique
dans ses je vous voyais réagir et je
m'en doutais mais dans ces 21 hommes ce
sont est-ce qu'il y a aussi beaucoup
d'hommes qui battaient leurs femmes et
elle a fini par se selon la
contre-volance dont on parlait je peux
pas la dire exactement sur ces 20 mais
par contre les statistiques vous les
avez dit on est quand même sur plus de
85 environ 85% de violence qui sont des
violences masculines sur des femmes et
il y a une raison en fait il y a une
raison à ça c'est un fait social qui
s'appelle le sexisme ce sont avant tout
toutes les violences intrafamiliales les
violences sexuelles aussi parce qu'on en
a pas parlé quand on a parlé des enfants
mais je rappellerai qu'il y a quand même
165 000 enfants qui sont victimes de
violences sexuelles et beaucoup dans le
cadre d'inceste et les violences
conjugales entre femmes et hommes ce
sont des violences sexistes et donc
l'essentiel des violences conjugales
c'est parce qu'il y a idéologie qui
imprègne les hommes qui pensent qu'ils
ont le droit et ils ont la légitimité de
battre leurs femmes et de frapper leur
femme et d'avoir
un certain nombre de droits sur leurs
femmes donc ça c'est jusqu'à une
juridiction genre comme en Espagne
d'abord c'est une fille qui ensuite
pareil parce que ça a été un peu dit sur
le mot féminin pardon le mot féminicide
et le mot crime passionnel le mot crime
passionnel justement il invite
visibilité le sexisme qui est le qui est
sous-jacent assez violentes là donc moi
je ne suis pas pour une juridiction que
pour les hommes ça n'aurait pas de sens
mais par contre dans la formation des
magistrats dans la formation de des
policiers d'avoir une formation qui
parle de sexisme et qui parle des des de
l'idéologie sexiste qui facilite et qui
légitime ces violences pour comprendre
aussi les phénomènes d'emprise de ces
hommes sur ces femmes c'est
indispensable pour comprendre le fait
social que représente ces violences
conjugales votre avis là-dessus alors
deux choses oui en Espagne c'est très en
Ré et donc c'est vraiment les hommes sur
les femmes et si jamais c'était un homme
sur un homme ça irait dans le tribunal
normal une femme sur un homme ça irait
dans le tribunal normal donc vraiment
c'est les zones sur les femmes alors non
nous ne sommes pas allés jusque là
d'autant que en Angleterre où on fait
des statistiques un peu plus poussées on
montre que dans un couple d'hommes il y
a 20% de plus de risques d'avoir de la
violence conjugale donc du coup nous
n'avons pas du tout j'en ai nos chambres
spécialisées évidemment c'est toute
violence intrafamiliale en sachant que
les enfants sont systématiquement de
toute façon victime quand bien même ne
reçoivent-ils pas directement les coûts
sur la formation je suis d'accord et
d'ailleurs la formation permet de savoir
si on est dans le conflit y compris
quand il y a des yeux au beurre noir des
deux côtés ou si on est dans la violence
parce que ça n'est pas du tout la même
chose or on sait montrer que dans le
cadre de la violence et dans 100% des
féminicides c'était présent il y a un
contrôle coercitif qui est mis en place
c'est-à-dire une stratégie de l'auteur
pour tenir sa victime sous emprise le
contrôle coercitif c'est simple c'est tu
gagnes ton argent mais tu n'as pas accès
à ta carte bleue tu t'habilles pas comme
tu veux tu sors quand je veux tu vois
qui je veux ça c'est du contrôle et dans
100% des cas de féminicides ce contrôle
était mis en place et là ça permet de
savoir combien même la femme se
serait-elle révélée et Monsieur
aurait-il un œil au beurre noir et
irait-il porter plainte à la police si
ce système a été mis en place c'est bien
lui l'auteur et pas elle alors on va
parler un peu du bilan du bilan
d'Emmanuel Macron depuis 6 ans qu'il est
pris dans la République Mathieu il y a
évidemment une ministre qui a en quelque
sorte un carnet le le combat pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et contre les violences faites aux
femmes c'est Marlène Schiappa oui
dont on se demande un peu ce qu'elle
était allé faire cette semaine en une de
Playboy comme si on y avait forcé non
Playboy lui a proposé en plein conflit
des retraites c'est quand même une drôle
d'idées pour une ministre qui fut celle
de l'égalité femme homme et de la lutte
contre toutes les discriminations
d'aller s'exprimer dans ce qui fut et ce
qui est peut-être encore pour certains
l'organe Casio officiel du sexisme et du
patriarcat afin de défendre la cause des
femmes justement la liberté des femmes à
disposer de leur corps et de lutter
contre les violences faites aux femmes
a-t-elle tenté de se justifier plus tard
quand on dit interview il y en a pas
tant que ça alors certains plaideront
lubrissent ce sentiment de des mesures
qui nous fait croire que tout est
possible d'autres inconscients qui nous
fait croire que on peut faire n'importe
quoi certains plaideront si la diversion
car coïncidence de calendrier ce coût
médiatique un peu plus fumeu que je
mange j'allais dire sort quelques jours
après une enquête journalistique celle
là dans laquelle Marlène Schiappa est
mise en cause concernant l'utilisation
douteuse et l'absence de contrôle de
fond alloué une association qui avait
été créée après la mort de Samuel Paty
pour défendre les principes républicains
en tout cas Marlène chapper n'aura pas
l'occasion de de justifier son choix de
communication cette semaine invité par
une chaîne de télévision elle a
finalement annulé bienvenue à la demande
d'Elisabeth borne qui a plutôt mal pris
son choix de poser en couverture de
Playboy donc cette interview a agacé
beaucoup agacé en haut lieu oui c'est
peu de le dire autant pour le choix du
titre que pour son sens du timing
défaillant quand même en plein conflit
sur les retraites ce qui est entre nous
est un peu hypocrite parce que quand le
chef de l'État lui-même évoque les
possibilités d'émission d'un président
de la République dans gadget c'est que
tout est permis et puis d'une certaine
façon il la connaissent par launch pas
c'est une femme de son époque c'est une
femme libérée comme l'a dit son ami
ancien ministre de tutelle Gérald
Darmanin en tout cas c'est quelqu'un qui
a toujours parlé de sexe librement sont
complexe elle a écrit des livres dessus
la même parfois amusé au Parlement quand
elle défendait les plans à trois vous
souvenez dans le cadre d'une législation
contre la polygamie une saillie qui lui
a valu le prix de l'humour politique
cette année là en France les femmes sont
libres n'en déplaise au rétrograder aux
hypocrites d'ailleurs réagi la
secrétaire d'État qui est aujourd'hui à
l'économie solidaire il faut rappeler et
à la vie associative Fe un peu moi je
trouve de ne pas voir que le problème
n'est pas là alors quel est le problème
mais il y en a deux à mes yeux le plus
surprenant c'est pas que malade Chapa
ait eu cette idée baroque après tout ça
lui ressemble et la ministre n'est pas à
son premier coup d'éclat dans le
problème c'est autour d'elle comme
au-dessus d'elle personne ne s'y soit
opposé ou non on est même été informé ce
qui est quand même un révélateur assez
inquiétant sur le fonctionnement du
sommet de l'État l'autre problème à mes
yeux il concerne Marlène Schiappa
elle-même parce que c'est une femme de
conviction mais on retient plus d'elle
aujourd'hui que sa communication en
choisissant Playboy pour défendre la
cause des femmes le sujet ne sait plus
ce qu'elle dit ni ce qu'elle fait c'est
devenu elle-même ce qu'elle aime Marlène
Schiappa on ne fait plus attention au
texte on ne regarde que les images vous
me direz c'est normal en exemple les boy
la femme politique a inventé d'une
certaine façon la plaiemate politique
qui n'enlève ni le haut ni le bas mais
qui dessert plutôt qu'elle ne sert son
combat je voudrais peut-être pas vous
entendre sur le cas marine Chapa et
Playboy mais peut-être sur le bilan de
d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce que vous dites
il y a eu beaucoup là je reprends une
partie de la démo de de Mathieu plus de
communication que d'action
alors de la part de Marlène Schiappa
peut-être mais elle a été suivie par
Elisabeth Moreno aujourd'hui il y a
Isabelle Rome et donc je pense que ce
sont des profils très différents et qui
ont aussi fait avancer les choses il y a
quand même eu pas mal d'avancées on
parle du bracelet anti rapprochement qui
a été voté alors après ça vient de tout
bord et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs je
crois pas forcément moi à la loi du
grand soir où on arrivera à faire une
loi cadre avec tout dedans en fait on se
rend compte que on arrive à faire passer
les choses au moment où on est prêt à le
faire passer je me souviens bien de
l'âge justement le fameux seuil en
dessous duquel aucun enfant n'est
consentant à une relation sexuelle cet
âge on avait essayé de le faire passer
justement auprès de Marlène Schiappa en
2017 on ne l'avait pas obtenu en 2019
grâce à la grande il faut le dire
la société était prête pour que ça passe
et c'est passé et donc je pense que sur
le droit des femmes malheureusement il
faut saisir le bon moment mais le
bracelet anti rapprochement est passé
cette loi qui protège les enfants et
passer un certain nombre de sujets sont
quand même passés aujourd'hui la
première ministre le ministre de la
Justice et évidemment Isabelle Rome sont
vraiment pour que les préconisations de
notre rapport dont je vous ai donné déjà
quelques lignes s'appliquent avant l'été
c'est à dire que ils sont en train de
regarder ce qui relève du réglementaire
beaucoup de choses donc ça va pouvoir se
mettre très rapidement en place et ce
qui relève de la loi qui doit
normalement passer avant l'été on va
regarder sur quel vecteur donc je pense
qu'il y a quand même des choses qui
s'accélèrent parce que de toute façon
c'est nécessaire et que tout le monde
les attend sur ce sujet là donc si ils
sont bien obligés d'avancer et de bouger
et je pense que ils essaient d'avancer
là encore de façon transpartisane sinon
j'aurais jamais été co-autrice de ce
rapport on va terminer sur la question
des des enfants on parle de protection
des victimes évidemment elle se pose
aussi je vous propose un témoignage les
témoignages des parents de Julie dweb
qui avait été assassiné par son
ex-conjoint la justice à cet homme
l'autorité parentale sur ces deux fils
âgés de 12 et 14 ans et voilà comment
les grands-parents Lucien et Juliette
Louis voulaient l'expliquer à leurs
enfants alors petits enfants pardon
cette décision alors expliquer
simplement comment on fait depuis tout
le temps que ils vont pouvoir vivre
tranquille ils vont pouvoir ne pas se
poser de question s'ils doivent lire ou
pas lire les lettres de leur père tu en
auras plus et ils vont pouvoir enfin
dire bah ouf tout simplement et on va
avancer de vivre comme ne plus avoir la
santé tous les petits garçons
pareil comme tous les petits garçons du
monde
Eric corbeau a un mari violence et
souvent aussi un père qui frappe ses
enfants
oui je crois qu'il y a pas de ça a été
dit et je crois que c'est une vraie
réalité on sait bien que des problèmes
d'ailleurs on parle de violence
intrafamiliale donc souvent les
violences conjugales sont concernent
aussi les enfants même s'ils ne
répondent pas au même ressort on a parlé
effectivement de l'emprise du contrôle
coercitif qui sont des choses qui sont
très spécifiques mais néanmoins on est
dans une démarche de violence et de
violence essentiellement masculines
comme ça a été dit qui se porte aussi
pour les enfants et d'ailleurs la loi
pour cela a évolué puisque désormais en
cas de certains nombre de crimes ou de
délits très graves l'autorité parentale
est automatiquement et immédiatement
retiré donc on termine avec ce sujet là
parce qu'effectivement c'est aussi faire
vivre des enfants et continuer à faire
situation abstenables
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce
débat Eric corbeau c'est une pique votre
avis là-dessus sur finalement moi ce que
je retiens c'est quand même que c'est
pôle spécialisés vont pouvoir
améliorer justement la prise en compte
aussi de de la situation pour les
enfants on peut ce sera un progrès on
verra si ce sera suffisant mais je
voulais peut-être revenir sur ce qui
était dit juste à l'instant sur les
enfants c'est extrêmement important je
pense que peut-être qu'on a gagné aussi
dans le l'opinion publique c'est
d'arrêter de penser que le maintien du
lien avec le père était nécessairement
absolu ça c'est quelque chose qui est en
train de changer ça c'est plutôt une
bonne chose le retrait de l'autorité
parentale j'espère qu'il sera plus
souvent acté qu'en cas de violence on
n'a pas encore réglé la question de
l'inceste qui a une autre violence
intrafamiliale je leur appelais tout à
l'heure 165 000 enfants et là encore on
a encore du chemin sur les violences
sexuelles sur les enfants on a le seuil
d'âge qui à mettre effectivement à
l'actif du gouvernement par contre on a
encore beaucoup beaucoup de maires qui
quand il y a le dénoncent
de leur ex-conjoint se retrouvent
poursuivi en justice pour non
représentations d'enfants en particulier
et il n'y a pas de mise à l'abri des
enfants donc quand on parlait de tout à
l'heure de la culture de la protection
il va falloir qu'on fasse la même chose
sur la question des enfants qui sont
aussi au cœur des violences
intrafamiliales merci beaucoup on
termine là-dessus je vais rappeler le
titre de vos livres Victoria vano la
paix déménages histoire des violences
conjugales qui est publiée aux éditions
anamosa
et puis je vous rappelle aussi la
diffusion voilà ce que j'étais en train
de rechercher du documentaire de Cécile
siksu c'est samedi 18h sur Public Sénat
le titre violence conjugale une justice
a la peine voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à toutes et à tous de
votre fidélité je vous dis à demain 18h
22h sur public c'est là et puis votre
prochain rendez-vous politique c'est
Patrick Canet qui sera l'invité de la
matinale il sera face à Oriane Mancini
le président du groupe socialiste ici au
Sénat belle soirée